[Music]
are you noticing the presidential uh ads
the presidential campaign ads are
already on the air yeah they're
bombarding us already the election is
until november uh-huh well in a new
campaign ad i don't know if you saw this
it just came out the obamas are on
camera and they say that on their first
date they saw spike lee's do the right
thing
that's in the ad yeah meanwhile i met in
ann romney's first date they uh saw a
guy who looked like spike lee and
immediately called the police
[Applause]
obama's really going after romney this
is the latest president obama called
mitt romney a pioneer of outsourcing
jobs
yeah a spokesman for romney said i dare
him to come to india and say that to my
face
i dare him
[Music]
hello this is gary yeah
the supreme court
has made a lot of decisions uh today the
supreme court has affirmed
that corporations can spend as much
money on political campaigns as they
want
that's the ruling yeah
yeah you don't like it but this decision
was praised by senator chevron p
mountain dude
[Music]
yesterday thousands of people marched
through the streets of new york city for
the gay pride parade
or as new yorkers call it the outdoor
tony awards
you were hillary clinton did this is a
weird story last week secretary of state
hillary clinton wore a string of mardi
gras beads to a swearing-in ceremony
yeah yeah the state department called
hillary's gesture lighthearted while
bill clinton called it 20 years too late
[Music]
science news a new kind of cosmetic
surgery for women
is out there removes body fat
and redistributes it to the breasts
yeah if you're interested in the
procedure just go to your doctor and ask
for the win-win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a better explanation than oh well
i had fat taken out of my ass and put in
my tits
i like your explanation better oh really
i thought you're what beats that
explanation i don't know it's fantastic
just doesn't seem like pillow talk is
off
guess what i did
here's a weird story in pennsylvania
four people were arrested for committing
a drive-by water gun attack
yeah if convicted they could face up to
two years in a federal bouncy castle
[Applause]
[Music]
somewhere dana carvey's watching and
he's very happy
or threatening to sue exactly
one or the other
this is weird it's being reported that
madonna madonna has her dressing rooms
sterilized after she leaves to remove
all traces of her dna
yeah which finally proves what i've been
saying since 1985 madonna is a serial
killer
jesus yes right
you all got on board with that
immediately
if i were madonna's people i'd be
worried that a random crowd right out
just got right on board with that well
they know why else would she need those
arms
seriously
you won't get free now